[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by cash up
as you know cash up is the simplest way
to send and save money and now it's the
simplest way to try to grow your money
introducing a cash app investing unlike
investing tools that only let you buy
entire shares of stock cash app lets you
instantly invest as little or as much as
you want this way when your favorite
company stock is just a little too
expensive you can still own a piece of
it with as little as $1 and because cash
up is directly connected to your bank
account there are no four or five day
waiting periods for inbound transfers so
you can start investing today brokerage
brokerage services are provided by cash
app investing a subsidiary of square and
member s I see and is always when you
sign up for cash up and use the promo
code Congrats not only will you
instantly receive 10 dollars but cash up
will also now donate 10 dollars to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
that provides crisis intervention and
suicide prevention services to LGBTQ
youth across America download cash app
from the App Store or Google Play Store
today
[Music]
it's congratulations podcast 147 and it
seems like look you guys listen to this
podcast you like this podcast if you
listen to if you're a longtime listener
you know you listen to the episodes to
me honestly I'm gonna be frank it seems
like we've been on episode 147 for 40
episodes but it's all good we can't get
the 150 I don't understand what's
happening
feels like we've been in the hundreds
way longer than we've been in that
[ __ ] before the hundreds don't know
what they call those but it's all good
but well one thing we do here one thing
we do here in congratulations podcast is
dude we don't [ __ ] we don't edit [ __ ]
we don't edit [ __ ] we don't edit [ __ ]
and we haven't really added a [ __ ] we've
edited maybe one or two things and it
was because something weird happened but
we don't do that when I order post mates
i order post mates in your to post mates
with me other podcasts that cut [ __ ] out
we don't do it we chill baby we sit and
we chill and you chill with me dude
because you know you know you what you
see is what you get dude a long time
listen or what you see is what you get I
don't give a [ __ ] if I do something
visual and you're listening to it on the
podcast I don't cut that out you don't
see it you don't see it and that's fine
much your life but whatever dude I'm
doing I'm doing Tampa Florida I'm going
to Tampa soon I got shows I think
they're all sold out Melbourne Florida
Hollywood Florida I keep opening up more
sections in the theater because you know
Dallas you know all good but Dallas you
know are good but bags and Dauntless so
El Paso we're coming at the Plaza
theater will be there November 29th at
the Plaza theater seeing Chris Lee it
bring his follow-the-leader tour highly
anticipated and missed visit Payton
Houston Texas coming out there we got a
renovation Music Center we got the Early
Show there sold out the Late Show we got
a little bit few shows levy the highly
anticipated
father loose or highly anticipated
anticipated and then Peoria Illinois for
some reason December 29th we're gonna be
playing the Peoria Civic Center
um Chicago celebrate New Year's Eve with
me dude
my hair is [ __ ] back under the the
headband of the [ __ ] whatever your
columns the beats by dre s now doesn't
my [ __ ] I don't like when the back
gets a little too long and it starts
coming forward and you start seeing the
[ __ ] duck bill the the duck the duck
but like my [ __ ] the back of my hair
looks like a duck but I don't like that
there's a flip-out yes does it [ __ ]
need to grow a little bit longer so it
stops flipping out yes will it no
because I'll cut it before that happens
and you won't dude that's my hair man
maximum flip that's what I call it back
there dude maximum flip and I and and I
[ __ ] came up with that with my friend
Ryan Davis I think he [ __ ] actually
came up with it calling it maximum flip
he used to call his [ __ ] abacus
maximum flip bro and I'll tell you what
dude do you think that I'll stop [ __ ]
saying that my whole life dude you think
I'll stop saying maximum flip about hair
at any point in my life nah that doesn't
happen when I say some [ __ ] it's part of
my [ __ ] and it keeps going dude so
that's fine
anyway maximum [ __ ] flip [ __ ] so it
is what it is dude and I'm just chilling
and I was here for a week in LA after I
shot my special in Minneapolis mini
Annapolis as I like to call it and and I
did it I did my special and now I
[ __ ] didn't do any Sh I didn't do any
[ __ ] shows dude because I made myself
take off and it was good sometimes you
just gotta I chilled I drank coffee you
know how I do I worked out hard check
work out hard check get coffee check
chill check you know
walked around the house check got coffee
and then went to go to get another
coffee at another coffee shop check you
think I drink a one [ __ ] coffee dude
I'll go back to back back to back I'll
go I'll go back to back on [ __ ]
coffees and you know like I pictured me
giving a [ __ ] picture me can you picture
that ha ha ha
nah dude remember last time I left on
the [ __ ] cliffhanger last last
episode left on a cliffhanger boss
[ __ ] at the Soho grand I'm not gonna
get into that yet but I looked at
Christmas trees man I went to this place
that's just [ __ ] an incredible place
that has all these Christmas trees I
can't even remember was but dude man
Christmas is when did Christmas jumped
the shark
look I love Christmas it's also so
annoying when people talk about how it's
annoying that that Christmas decorations
go up too early it doesn't matter it's
one of those things that it's like you
it's annoying as it's as annoying as
what your annoying annoying about what
you're doing you know it's like it's
it's like just christmas is coming stuff
isn't coming christmas is coming and
it's fine now look it's fine that
christmas is coming you know but if you
want to be [ __ ] you know not involved
in it then don't be involved in it when
people don't like in LA like all right
head you go to the Grove and it's
[ __ ] over there first of all don't go
to the Grove okay if you're going over
the Grove you're gonna have the most
grooviest experience of all time and the
most grooviest experience of all time is
Christmas at the Grove in LA you go to
the Grove and it's like during Christmas
time you have like it's it's like an
outdoor mall or whatever la has some
outdoor malls cuz it never [ __ ] rains
why would you live anywhere else and so
and so they had they decorated in like
[ __ ] August starting for Christmas
because they want to make [ __ ] bags
and they want to remained honest and I
get it dude they want to remain Donal US
but um people complain about it dude
it's the most annoying thing it's not
that annoying when you go to the Grove
and there's [ __ ] garland around who
cares you just don't look at it or don't
go to Topshop you know or you can get a
suit for $25 a three-piece suit for $25
and that rips on the red carpet oh
really
hey top gear at Topshop hey how much is
this [ __ ] three-piece suit 17 bucks
really yeah can I try it on no it'll rip
alright I'll take it you know it's like
hmm when you're like wow this [ __ ]
jack is pretty gnarly dude I'm gonna get
this cool bring it up dude
accept it boom go sign here great sorry
cool
yeah let me just say I head on another
shop and get get to my car okay bye guys
rip what's H&M several de Mol it's gonna
rip soon dude if this is another cup
podcast we will cut that part out but we
don't do it
raw which is let's get holy moly
H&M holy moly uh yes so I saw a
Christmas tree with the [ __ ]
flamingos all over it
bye hey big tall flamingos all over the
Christmas tree you know don't put things
as big as the Christmas tree on the
Christmas tree you know Christmas tree
with the big dip some people will put
big-ass presents in the Christmas tree
like to hang them up on there it looks
bad now I'm gonna be honest with you it
looks bad
also dude christmas is coming okay and
and if you're annoyed that christmas is
coming
we'll be annoyed at the podcast because
this podcast is saying christmas is
coming and it's already it's only
November okay but it's never a flamingo
Christmas okay sometimes I see things
online I saw I think online said it's a
very merry flamingo Christmas guess what
it's not ever a flamingo Christmas but
dude I saw ones with [ __ ] like I mean
there's somewhere where Christmas with
sharks on it and [ __ ] probably but
there's so much decorations on Chris
his trees in these [ __ ] Christmas
tree places and I get it is because this
is their life and this is their due
dates are getting ready to display these
Christmas it's like those Halloween
shops they're just only they only really
function in October that's like how
you're not going out of business these
Christmas places they're ready to get
they're ready to get going in August you
know see so they decorate every last
part it's like my mom on [ __ ] meth my
mom if you go to her house every little
place has got tchotchkes all over it go
ahead it yes is she my mom yes do I love
her still yes but dude tchotchkes
everywhere man and this Christmas place
they got bows they got tinsel they've
got [ __ ] flamingos they've got and
it's just so much [ __ ] to it anyway what
I like is red and green and I like the
Christmas trees that are the ornaments
are hung up different ornaments so it
looks like a family did it I don't like
this store-bought [ __ ] why would you
take the feeling at a Christmas is your
house your house or is it Bloomingdale's
you know if you have kids make the kids
hang up the [ __ ] School Bus ornaments
or whatever the [ __ ] you know that's it
um my my grandpa would would would would
would have his kid his kids do the trees
and my which was my dad obviously if you
know anything about lineage and my and
he would be like he would sit in his
chair and it would be like put it that
go right there that's where that one
goes and my dad would be like here and
from the chair my grip up there will be
like no right there might that'll be
like this one here now it is a spot
right there right here right there's
were important not that there and he'd
be like [ __ ] 20 feet out
that's what I'm gonna do to my kid dude
put it there where they're where they're
right here did I [ __ ] say they're
there and he's gonna be three I don't
know what to do where to put this it's
too high to put up there I can't get up
there
jump use a step stool have your mother
[ __ ] hold you up there there hey you
there you hold him there we're here dad
hold him here yeah now put it there son
put it there where there here everyone
just screaming there at my whole family
another I daughter
we're not put this one there put it give
it to [ __ ] him hold him
have your mother hold him for couldn't
you hold our dare hang up the [ __ ]
star on this one is at the top there um
did I can't wait to have kids and make
them crazy [ __ ] dude
yeah so and also hey I got some news for
you man I know that shit's crazy about
the in the holiday season we always keep
here in the [ __ ] hey it's not a
Christmas tree it's a holiday tree I
don't give a [ __ ] what it is dude call
it a holiday tree what the [ __ ] do I
care who cares call it a Subaru what's
it matter dude it's green and you hang
[ __ ] School Bus ornaments on it you
put tensile all over it who cares there
was this one guy who tweeted this is not
a holiday tree it's a Christmas tree
okay okay
okay all right cool good have a [ __ ]
have have dinner what do I give a [ __ ]
you call it you call it when someone
gets mad hey this is a Christmas tree
okay you mean the holiday tree imagine
being like no no I mean Christmas tree
imagine getting that mat if I say that's
a Christmas tree you mean a holiday tree
I go like this Yeah right there who
gives a [ __ ] the people who are outraged
it should stop with the people who are
outraged you don't get more outraged who
gives you
[ __ ] man that being said sometimes your
blue gets outraged but yeah man that's
so weird when somebody gets mad this
isn't a holiday candle this is a [ __ ]
what do they call the Chanukah things
menorah
so we now is it weird that menorah if
you shortened the word its menorah and I
mean [ __ ] yes have I always thought that
yes what came first menorah or menorah
dunno but I'm pretty sure horses were
shittin for [ __ ] centuries and
centuries Wow didn't why didn't Jude why
weren't Jews like I'll boy maybe we
should change it let's call it a menorah
well okay but that sounds like horseshit
what the hell does it matter who cares
light them up what should we call it
poopy candles a menorah
well can't call a poopy not pull the
candles or emac cuz it's got poo pee in
it menorah it is hey dude whatever you
can't get mad at me I'm Jewish
I don't I'm a dude man people are so
[ __ ] I don't want to always talk
about how people are outraged but
everybody's [ __ ] outraged get the
holiday trees holiday candles how about
the lady that was [ __ ] talking about
on Twitter about the [ __ ] comedy club
oh this [ __ ] was so funny
god this [ __ ] was so funny I I tweeted
it let me [ __ ] do it here it's right
here god this made me laugh dude
Courtney pong her name is tonight I shut
down a string of misogynistic stand-up
comics as in I've walked on stage in the
middle of one of them talking addressed
the audience offered a full refund told
them it would not be
tolerated here and pulled the show and
then a follow-up tweet and it's comics
from our theater and put oh and it
pulled the show and it's comics from our
theater immediately
lights on go home I haven't this was the
best part I have never felt more alive
than not right now hey good ok this is
the best because obviously she can do
what she wants if it's her comedy club
great
you can put whoever whatever comics you
want on there but dude if you want to
control what people are saying and what
jokes they're making don't have a comedy
club how bad is it gonna be holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] the people the people that were
responding we're killing dude the fact
that that makes her feel alive is so
funny you ever been wrong in front of a
bunch of people you know how alive you
feel when that happens or just when
you're bombing on stage you know how
live you feel that's what she was doing
feeling alive because she was being
wrong dude don't have a comedy show if
you're gonna say you know it's like the
best thing about the comedy story is you
go up there you you you know you work
your [ __ ] out you fail if you fail and
you succeed if you succeed but nobody's
saying don't say this don't say that
Mitzi shore rolling over in a [ __ ]
grave so funny safe comedy as an unfunny
comedy so I wrote this I wrote just
crying emoji crying laughing emoji and
somebody somebody
somebody wrote something like I don't
get why are you laughing this is a good
thing somebody wrote and I immediately
made this all about myself
wondering how on it no so there were 17
people in the audience dude this was the
article about it though there was an
article written terribly in some [ __ ]
stupid thing here it is it was called
the universal hub calm okay
misogynist comedians stay out of
Rosalynn Dale made-up town that [ __ ]
it's you know would be in a [ __ ] WB
show Roslindale tonight on Roslindale a
girl with red hair gets upset the owner
of a comedy spot in Roslindale shutdown
issues of stand-up sets last night after
she says she'd had enough of a string of
racist sexist jokes I love that the word
jokes is in there like okay once that
happens everything's moot
Courtney pong who owns the Razi Square
Theatre shortened it's a [ __ ] to say
it's the Rajee square oh wait I want to
write this down dad with over the next
40 minutes is her so she runs it
improvident let's other group put on
stand-up shows over the next 40 minutes
or she cringe listened to a number of
this [ __ ] jokes and finally had enough
when one guy told a joke about how you
couldn't understand why you were fired
him for making women customers ride in
the trunk like okay fine I'm sure that's
a bad joke I wasn't there it was
probably stupid but like so funny to see
it in writing like that was way that she
said is when she realized wait a minute
I own this place
should've realized it sooner it's your
place don't ever forget that sitting at
the sound table in the back of the
theater she hit a button that rang a
loud Bell wow dude you know Big Brother
walked into the front and announced the
night was over and that she would give
refunds to the for paying customers and
the other 13 people in the room were
friends of the performers yeah no [ __ ]
she wrote it's not okay she says it's
not okay it's not who we are she told
the audience is and somebody from the
audience said is this a joke or is this
part of the Act
pong said she chose rosin Dale very
deliberately as a site for a 49 seat
theater to get away from stuff like this
then thought even though she knew she
could have made a lot more money
someplace like downtown oh man then she
wrote no woman in the world would have
wanted to stand in that room laughs last
night I mean that's not true
it's so [ __ ] egotistical to think
that everybody just wants to feel what
you feel and hear what you hear and
think what you think it's like how could
you [ __ ] have that in your head just
if you don't want to run your business
the way that's fine but you're not gonna
get good comedians to do it that's it
anyway that's all I want to say about
that but it was so [ __ ] funny and my
buddy Earl Skakel rope under it he wrote
where is the in quotes where is this gig
and can I have an incredible set there
and he put a picture of Jeremy Piven
under it can I have an incredible set
there that's so funny
Jeremy Piven does stand-up um anyway no
it's all good driven to snow so you know
in a [ __ ] hat Jeremy Piven just stand
up in a [ __ ] hat that you'd buy it
[ __ ] gore misen and corns in or
whatever the [ __ ] that place is called
Oh for [ __ ] sake sir me Pittman
doesn't stand up in a [ __ ] Ascot and
a and a and a hat goodbye from groomsmen
and Gorman's men or whatever the [ __ ]
that stupid place is magic by de hat at
[ __ ] Gorman and goons men what the
[ __ ] it called Goran and gums in Goran
bros oh for [ __ ] sake hats from Goran
bros imagine wearing a [ __ ] hat
premium head where it's called nope wear
a hat premium head wear of course the
[ __ ] goddamn picture the main picture
in the Fall collection on the website is
a guy staring at goats egg Guardsmen go
[ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself imagine staring at
[ __ ] 22 goats dude there's a guy's
like leaning up against the barn dude
let me tell you something right now
[ __ ] all photo shoots that are at a barn
for real dude you're not extra
good-looking because you took a picture
near some hay that's it so annoying you
got all the layers on and you're near a
[ __ ] a horse you're not good-looking
cuz you took a picture near some [ __ ]
wood dude that's so annoying man fotage
you know what I got a really cool place
we got it you know it's a place it's
just like 20 honestly it's just 20
minutes outside it's near kiste ik we
take a drive and the traffic is coming
back it's just so bad it's unbelievable
you wish you wish you [ __ ] hung
yourself
but what go out there we'll take a few
pictures as Nuka steak leg you know
there's a bar in there and we take a
picture just a [ __ ] I'll bring a
horse and you big good-looking dude
it'll pop you up a notch or two on the
[ __ ] 1 through 10 scale dude Goran
I'm gonna get some [ __ ] Goran hats
for real I'm gonna get some [ __ ]
Goran hats and I'm gonna rock it and I'm
gonna do stand-up with it and I'm gonna
kill it do it I'm gonna go on before
Jeremy Piven as I walk out but I'm like
dude this is the new one you don't have
this one just [ __ ] anytime you got
designer head where o bird with just a
cool casual white t-shirt you know cuz
you're killing it over in Venice and
got some [ __ ] stupid dog some stupid
like [ __ ] dog that looks like at his
breathing problems you don't have an
album you know don't get a [ __ ] Goran
hat get a personality period learn
karate you [ __ ] you know what I mean
look at the names of these [ __ ] hats
deagle deagle dude are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me look at the name of this one
hat it's called you're amazing oh you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude look at this
dude
treat Street well cool never been more
mad why aren't people outraged at this
[ __ ]
are you kidding me look at this [ __ ]
hat it's called Canyon reef
go [ __ ] yourself dude do you fish in it
of course is one called cloud nine oh
there's a hat called yes ma'am dude the
only time you would the only person who
would wear a hat called yes ma'am is
somebody who [ __ ] straight up does
date rape this is my yes man oh this
hats called the gasps ma'am
oh really [ __ ] no dude me Dean the
butcher elevated that's a clunky vodka
soda
oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] are you
kidding me this this hat called the
[ __ ] the director bro they're all the
[ __ ] called the director look at them
all Fatima Beverly Corleone come on keep
going the saloon the occasion I'll do it
that's like [ __ ] do you know how much
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] ego you have to have
to [ __ ] name a hat
the Thomas Santiago a better man dude
this is hat is called a better man
patty-cake this is actually better than
when I was reading the names for the
[ __ ] whatever the let me just read
some of these keep it this way oh don't
move it Players Club okay fine
dreamboat Waterway charlie grateful all
right dude
Charlie grateful sounds like a [ __ ]
rat
that would come out in 1999 yeah what's
up is Charlie grateful and he would wear
all purple yo was any way to have a hat
that every every song that's that that
starts with part of me ma'am how you
doing
like dude Charlie grateful would have a
[ __ ] song in 1999 that would come out
and it would start with part of me ma'am
how you doing I'm just trying to get a
Papa - Papa - Boop booming babble a bit
of boom ends up booming I'm Charlie
grateful spell it backwards be bit
grateful grateful Charlie be able to pop
pop pop dude there's a [ __ ] hat
called fancy dog there's a hat called
the new guy and there's a hat called
trumpet blues all those [ __ ] hats
were the NBC lineup in 2004 I swear to
God
tonight after fancy dog join tonight
after the fancy dog an all-new trumpet
blues with [ __ ] an all new trumpet
blues with [ __ ] the guy who's with a
guy who's a little bit Mexican but not
too much so white people who watch him
on a new trumpet blues Jorge on a new
trumpet blues George Lynn des landes
that what is this a Mexican is it begins
with a Mendez but Landis on an all-new
trumpet blues starring George Len Dez
and Monique we got the perp come on
let's move out
he's got a [ __ ] Charlie Grateful hat
with the soundtrack from Charlie
grateful
what's up ma'am how you doing I'm
Charlie grateful make a go lower what
are these hat names dude
how about the fact that they're straight
up 500 hats you can buy good have 17 and
push those this [ __ ] some crazy guy
decide now keep megawhatts call this
when they tried the Grateful man like I
don't know it'll sell [ __ ] put it out
there call this one the knocks Duncan
but holy [ __ ] dude and all-new the
glider after double take and all-new the
glider starring Geoff Stults after the
after double take
starring [ __ ] some girl that was that
that was that [ __ ] who's that guy
goddamn who's that guy who played
Jennifer Aniston's friend boyfriend and
friends who no no not him oh that's good
though Tom yeah Tom Selleck would for
sure be that guy the glider and all new
the glider after baron
after the baron in all new knocks duncan
p i there's you could put p i after any
of these hat names and it would be a
[ __ ] show mr. cash p i southern coast
p i double take p i conrad p i
contrarian p i while these [ __ ] [ __ ]
hats dude these [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
hats imagine a guy wearing this hat
knees 5 6 god these [ __ ] hats alright
[Music]
alright we're gonna do some [ __ ] ads
god these Goran [ __ ] hats they're
probably gonna be a sponsor soon quit
what actually makes it better I got a
question for you in this is serious what
actually makes a better toothbrush
industrial strength power claims of
maracas trendy ingredients multiple
modes if ask your dentist say it's less
about the brush and more about how you
use it that's why quip was created by
dentists and product designers to focus
on what actually matters for your oral
health
healthier habits equip sensitive
vibrations with a built-in timer guide
gentle brushing for the dentist
recommended 2 minutes with 30 second
pulses ensuring and even clean I love it
because you do it you'd brush Nick
you're like okay that's enough time
they're over here and there you go no
cavities it's sleek it's an intuitive
design it's simple to use comes with a
travel cap that doubles as a mirror
mount very cool I take it on the road
with me good habits matter to live a
healthier life so help form fresh oral
health habits with quip grip starts at
just $25 and you'll get your first free
refill free at get quip Comstock
congrats this is a simple way to support
our show and to start brushing better
but you have to go to get qu IP comm /
congrats to get your first refill free
go right now to get qu IP comm slash
Congrats Roman look most guys have tried
different ways to last longer but saying
the Pledge of Allegiance in your head
are counting backwards from 10 or trying
to list all the Goron hats it doesn't
always work that's what I would do and I
would have sex I try to list all the
Goron hats I'd be like uh what was it
charlie good night mr. Murphy I'd just
be starting Barron
you know I just be doing that and all of
a sudden I can't do it
the folks at Romina men's health company
are changing the name changing the game
with Roman swipes this is the secret to
longer-lasting sex
Romans wife's swipes are clinically
proven to last long to help you last
longer in bed they're effective easy to
use and fast-acting but don't require a
prescription so that's what's cool about
it Roman can ship swipes to you and
discreet unmarked some people get
embarrassed I don't get embarrassed who
cares about that stuff but they if you
do they send you and they send it to you
in unmarked packaging and each swipes
packet is small enough to hide in your
wallet so nobody gets to see until you
need it and even when you need it they
still don't get to say they're super
easy to use to take them out of the
package swipe it on let it dry and
you're good to go that's it get $10 off
your first order of swipes and free
2-day shipping at get Roman comm slash
babies that's get Roman comm slash
babies for $10 off and free 2-day
shipping get Roman comm slash babies
good for now okay um dude those hats
those [ __ ] hats uh this is the kind
of arguments I get in my family I get
into my family these are the kind of
arguments I get in with ham in with my
family I should say on friends way hold
on I want to see this guy's name what
was his name
Ross Geller it says none that's not what
I want Eddie I think is who's this guy
who gives a [ __ ] I don't care all right
look uh my dad went to go put some
[ __ ] calamari he had two pieces of
calamari on his fork now this is the
important [ __ ] I like talking about this
has nothing to do with world events or
current events but this [ __ ] is
seriously the kind of stuff that I think
about and I want to know about my dad
had to Calamari's on his fork okay
one was on the fork obviously more than
the other one because one was on it
first the other one was on it and I
could tell it was on it precariously he
didn't really poke it hard enough now
when I saw him do that and not fix it I
was like I noticed it now I noticed it
because I'm [ __ ] Charlie goodnight
[ __ ] what is it P i okay I'm on the
NBC lineup in 2003 I'm a PI baby so I
saw it and I thought well he's been
dipping them in the sauce it's on
precariously he's not gonna [ __ ] it
he's gonna lose it in the [ __ ] sauce
all right now I'm watching him do it
sure enough he goes to dip it in loses
it in the sauce there's still some
losses one of them in the sauce there's
still the other calamari or if your
piece of [ __ ] calamari in America you
say it like that if you're tying is that
kalamata q not a piece of [ __ ] if you're
in here he's a calamari
your piece yeah okay
so there's some sauce on the one that's
not in the sauce
well that's doused obviously in the
sauce so there's one and he eats it and
then I go oh you didn't know that was
gonna happen
and he says huh
and I said you didn't know you're gonna
[ __ ] lose that one in the sauce and
he says I don't care and I said and then
he goes and grabs it out of the sauce
with the fork and puts in his mouth I
said there's too much sauce on that one
huh and he says nah now um you know it's
like first of all have a goddamn opinion
about something dad okay have a goddamn
opinion about something all right if
you're gonna put a [ __ ] fork in a
calamari put it in the calamari if you
want to get to Calamari's [ __ ] poke
the whole goddamn to Calamari's all
right if you're gonna dip it in the
sauce do that if you gonna dip it in the
sauce for sure poke the two Calamari's
all right this [ __ ] guy has one
calamari in the fork and another one
dangling off like it's a boogie all
right
dips it in leaves the one in the sauce
it's the original one that was on low
and I say I didn't know that was gonna
happen and he looks at me and he says I
don't care and then he eats it and I
said there's too much sauce on that one
- huh he says no I liked it holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude this kind of thing is not
something that I [ __ ] live all right
dude I I said to him you didn't again I
said you didn't know that you were gonna
lose that calamari in the sauce and he
says I don't care that it happened and I
said dad that's not the [ __ ] question
I'm asking you did you know you were
gonna lose the calamari in the sauce and
he said no I don't think I did and I
said well that's what makes you a
[ __ ] bad detective and me a good
detective man and he says but I didn't
think about it and I didn't care and I
said
I actually don't remember what I said at
that point but I do remember him then
taking the [ __ ] calamari in the thing
and eating it and I said that's too much
sauce on that calamari and you [ __ ]
know it and he says no I liked it and
then the next thing he did was take
calamari out of the calamari ball and
put it in his mouth with no sauce dude
like you dude how much sauce do you want
on each calamari either dude how [ __ ]
funny is it that he was just like
carefree chilling oh I want some sauce
on this calamari I want total sauce on
this calamari and you know what oh let
me go nuts and have no sauce on this
dude oh my god man find out the way duty
72 how do you like to eat calamari how
do you like to eat calamari
how much sauce you like on the calendar
this guy's just willy-nilly trying to
scoop out [ __ ] Calamari's like it's
that [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] thing
that we try to grab a Pokemon or a
[ __ ] Teletubby out of a thing and you
can never do it because you always grab
it out of the that you're puttin a cord
and you grab it and you got it a little
bit and you're like oh put it over to
the drop it and then it drops too soon
what do you call that [ __ ] thing kind
of a car at a carnival what is it
grabbing game crane crane that's what it
is
this guy's just doesn't know how he
likes his calamari he's 72 years old
don't know how like his calamari do you
best believe when I get a [ __ ] ice
cream sundae I tell them to put if
anything comes with sauce to it you put
the sauce on the side I'll take the [ __ ]
with the spoon and I'll decide how much
sauce goes on each [ __ ] bike dude and
I'm not even [ __ ] 40 and I know that
I'm the young that's coming to you
straight
from the youngest man alive I'm the
youngest man you've ever met dude I'm
the youngest man you've ever heard of
and I know this and my 72 year old
father is just willy-nilly dropping
calamari everywhere and then sometimes
just tossing him in his mouth like it's
a [ __ ] potato chip with no sauce or a
popcorn I should say
oh we were [ __ ] laughing dude also I'm
gonna post a video in a little bit my
dad [ __ ] it when he says bye he's so
Italian first of all he grabs the back
of my [ __ ] head and he says I'll see
you later and [ __ ] gives me a kiss on
the cheek which is fine that's cool I
like that [ __ ] but it's always so
[ __ ] high dude and every time he does
it I try to get on my tippy-toes at the
last minute so he misses and hits my
cheek
and I'm like dad you [ __ ] kiss my eye
dude and he's like that's not your eye
this is your right this is your ID
starts poking my [ __ ] eye and I'm
like dad and he's like look look look
let me just show you this is your cheek
this is where I'm gonna kiss you and he
kisses me on the [ __ ] right here dude
right here if you're watching a video
okay it's right here who kisses somebody
on the [ __ ] cheekbone for real i'ma
go lower dude go here kiss [ __ ] here
it's like the old a1 steak sauce
commercial gets you here get you right
here
kiss where the guy's pointing on the
[ __ ] commercial dude it's so no no it
grabs it's so [ __ ] aggressive and
high come on and then I go to kiss my
mom my mom goes right on my [ __ ]
cheek words should be right like we're
the teeth meet you know um they don't
want to post that video it's probably on
my Instagram right now um so you guys
know how to dip your calamari mother
I've never had calamari in my life never
had kennel money in my life
and that [ __ ] won't have calamari in
my life I don't think that that's the
kind of thing I want to do dude never
had calamari in my life I don't do
things until I regret I haven't done
them that's how it goes it's why I never
smoked me that's why I never [ __ ]
drank alcohol that's why I didn't lose
my virginity till I was 19 I didn't lose
my regime until I was 19 dude you know
why because I wanted to make sure I
wanted to do it and then when I
regretted I didn't have sex with that
one girl one time that was when I knew I
was ready and wanted to have sex it's
like when you're shopping
you go out I don't want to buy that coat
let me leave the shop you leave the shop
damn should have bought that coat that's
when go back you buy the coat now me
Darla's buy the coat anyway at this
point in my life um all right where's my
other [ __ ] ads then I'm gonna get
into somehow it [ __ ] [ __ ] stories
go Yeezys Jordans off whites if you're
gonna buy sneakers for a few hundred
dollars how can you be sure there's a
real thing I'll tell you how go that's
where I get all my sneakers from goat
comm is the safest way to buy and sell
authentic sneakers online they're the
largest marketplace in the world for
authentic Easy's Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listings they've made
the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy they do this by only
accepting sellers with the best
reputation and by verifying all sneakers
to ensure there are that authenticity
for buyers every detail is inspected
from the stitching in color to the size
and weight Goat certifies that every
pair of sneakers on their site message
matches exact factory specifications
think about that they check the size and
the weight if it's if it's a little off
they're not real they sent them back to
the guy who tried to try to get you on
them tried to get you on him but they
didn't with so fine find the perfect
100% authentic sneaker at Goat calm
slash Congrats
that's goat comm / Congrats plus you'll
also be supporting our show and that's
cool I use goat I use goat comm you got
to go right now before the sneakers you
want are gone trust me when you go to
goat comm / Congrats spell Geo 80 comm /
Congrats they've got the coolest shoes
on there man you guys heard a use ition
I have did you know that as many as
seven out of 10 adults wish they played
a musical instrument that's so many
that's 70 percent unfortunately many
never do because they think it's either
too late for them to start too expensive
or feel they don't have time well all
this is crap do it it's not true
musician is an online music education
platform rethinking the way people learn
music you can learn and you can do this
and it's not too late
you got years and years left it's the
fun easy and affordable way to learn a
guitar piano bass ukulele or even
singing that's right
learn how to do that even better to
download the apps your desktop tablet or
phone and start playing use ish ins
award-winning technology actually
listens to you play and gives you
real-time feedback on timing accuracy no
need for cords or special equipment and
it doesn't with singing to with use ish
and you'll learn how to play your
favorite songs faster than ever and have
fun doing it it is fun man they show you
how to do it I was using it and they
they teach you how to like hit notes and
stuff I'd bend it I go ah and I hit it
and it would and it shows green when you
hit the note and it's dope if you've
been wanting to learn an instrument or
simply want some help getting back to
playing check out use ition you can get
an extend 14 day trial of their premium
plus package at use ition comm /
congrats the unlimited that's unlimited
lessons and Eltham and unlimited songs
on as many instruments as you want for
the whole two weeks go to use ition calm
/ congrats to start your free trial
today
that's why oh you s I see I am calm /
congrats congratulations is brought to
you by cash out the official app of the
log cabin speaking of you I'm gonna be
in you uh who's this oh yeah hell yeah
um my manager just emailed me well and
I'm gonna email back because it's
respectful we are setting a meeting with
the director for this week that's what's
up dude
I might be doing another movie hell yeah
hell yeah I'm writing back hell yeah -
Josh Lieberman no uh yeah so anyway
imagine getting one of those Goran hats
and thinking that's cool I can't believe
it took pictures near some goats uh
yeah so let me tell you the stories it's
a cliff hang you last time
uh when I [ __ ] myself at the Soho grand
dude I actually didn't actually didn't
cuz I told the [ __ ] Freddy Krueger
story twice in this podcast already
worth of well I took a dump in my red
shorts at Crystal's house because I was
scared because Freddy was gonna get me
dude I was at I went to go to my
cousin's Bar Mitzvah he's like the only
Jewish kid in our family so I felt like
I should go I wanted to support him my
family was there flew to New York the
bar mitzvah was in New Jersey flew to
New York because I was on the road
already and I was going to meet my
remember I was married my ex-wife I was
like twenty [ __ ] six I was gonna meet
her there and I was staying at the Soho
grand for one night before she got there
or something and anyway I felt good you
know married guy out on the [ __ ] town
got to New York early nothing to do I
was on the road didn't have a show that
night woke up early feeling good dude
you know when you're jet-lagged you go
from west to east and you wake up early
or you go east to west you wake up early
whatever it is you know you're all
[ __ ] up I went from west to east I
woke up early I was like you know what I
got enough sleep I'm fine
let's do this get up I'm just gonna walk
around I went to college here for a year
so I was gonna walk around look at the
area I hadn't been there for a bit ah
I'm feeling good it was one of those
[ __ ] times where you wake up and
you're just like you know you wake up
sometimes and just so I see a few blocks
down one of those bagel place like those
like carts that sell bagels and eggs and
bacon and [ __ ] and I go one please eat
it keep walking as I'm walking I'm
eating it I see another cart coffee
Hey look it's got cool coffees maybe it
was a [ __ ] actually it was like one
of those bidets
like a little half store and I say one
please now I'm eating the [ __ ] bagel
and I'm drinking the coffee and I'm and
I'm walking and I'm taking a walk and
it's it's still early the streets aren't
even bustling yet but the Sun is out
now I'm keep walking I took my last but
last sip of coffee and I feel on the top
of my stomach now that's fine sometimes
your stomach just goes alright but I
keep walking because it's nothing if I
need I can go to the bathroom in one of
these places it's all good
keep walking and all of a sudden I feel
now the first time I felt wrong the
second time I felt there were double
rows okay
she's like man maybe should go to the
bathroom now kept walking okay also
those bathrooms everywhere it's New York
[ __ ] City so now I'm like uh you know
what I actually don't really know what's
up and my stomach doesn't really feel
too well so I'm like I'm just gonna turn
around what if we weren't doing anyway
you know I was gonna walk back where am
I going
I'm just chilling I'm just gonna walk
back so I start to walk back and as soon
as I pivot to walk back I feel cool or
or or or or or all oh that's much longer
than the first one so I think well you
know what I'll do I'd obviously I've got
to go to the bathroom I'll walk back to
the hotel I'll go back I'll go to the
bathroom at the hotel and if I need to
I'll stop before that in one of these
great fantastic shops that exist in New
York City so I'm walking I'm walking and
the contractions are happening you know
closer together
little roller I'm walking taking a few
steps pretty soon that turns into a
little bit of a [ __ ] oh okay oh my
god well you know what I'm actually
gonna try and find a [ __ ] spot to
just unload you know I mean
so I try to get into this one place it's
close I'm like hey whatever oh [ __ ] I
see it's close Malone oh alright well
[ __ ] it
keep walking keep walking and I realize
and this is where I get mad because it's
New York City
nothing's open it's too early but it's
New York [ __ ] City though dude so in
my head not only is [ __ ] Laurel going
on but also I'm like dude this is New
York I'm gonna have a look at this is
New York [ __ ] City and none of these
[ __ ] places are open it's 8 a.m. why
are none of these places open I got a
[ __ ] unload so now I'm like well at
least I have the hotel I can get back to
and I don't sort of thinking man is this
too [ __ ] far away dude is my [ __ ]
gonna give out are the levees gonna
break so I start walking fast and now
I'm like where's the [ __ ] place I
gotta go I'm like do I go slow enough to
check and see if places are open or do I
hit a full sprint and just hope to get
back to the hotel and I don't know so I
check one more place it's closed and
that's when I decide Chris it's gonna be
the hotel in a Stan and I hit a full
splint sprint I hit a full sprint back
to the Soho grand and I'm far from it
and I'm getting and there are times to
where I'm like holy [ __ ] I don't know if
I'm gonna make it I'm clenching so hard
I get to the soul grant as soon as I see
the Soho grand my [ __ ] it starts to I
start to open up I'm like oh this is not
gonna be good okay I think the hotel
elevator better be on the floor that I'm
on cuz if I have to wait for it
oopsy-daisy okay so I get to the
elevator the [ __ ] doors open I don't
even hit it I'm like thank God people
are in it they get out I get on I hit
the button as I'm going up in the
elevator to my floor I'm unbuckle in my
pants
I can't I can't
spare any second all right the door
opens and my [ __ ] underwear is that
I'm not if someone's there I don't give
a [ __ ] you know imagine some of the door
open all of a sudden I just wanna move
throw up and just [ __ ] all over
everywhere that'd be amazing for them
for them to tell that story anyway I run
down the hall to I get my key out I'm
running down holding my pants i unlock
the door who do root now this is the
part dude there's in the room there's a
hallway to the bedroom that goes to the
right pass this like final 4-foot
hallway is the bathroom door okay now if
I'm looking at the if I'm open if I'm
opening the bathroom door or if I'm
opening the hotel door there's the
hallway I have to step through that that
goes perpendicular to the where how I'm
facing I don't the run down the hallway
after cross always you see one side and
then there's the bathroom and the
bathroom is set up to where the toilet
is to the if I'm looking at it the
toilets on the left and it's facing out
towards the right okay so picture the
toilets not facing me it's on the left
and it's facing to the right okay so I
have already worked out that I'm going
to take off my pants and I'm going to do
a spin move and and sit on the toilet
and as I'm sitting on the toilet
I'm going to let loose okay so I see the
toilet soon as I see the toilet the plan
is [ __ ] because you know when you see
a toilet and you got to go you're gonna
go right so I decide that oh [ __ ] it's
coming out I do a an even quicker spin
move and like a [ __ ] Gatling gun it
just hits all the side of the wall one
of those guns that with the circles you
know
like that trying to get the predator and
it just covers the [ __ ] and I sit on
the toilet most of it gets in the toilet
and I just go and I never felt better
dude relief bro
and then I cleaned it up and that was
the [ __ ] most I'm just what I want
dude it was the word it was the worst
office so good when you go doesn't it it
feels like whoever you voted for for
president won
that's what it feels like you're just
like oh make America great again man you
want to do some things what are you
calling Craigslist okay he wants me to
see this one thing wanted real quick so
far it's what is this [ __ ] Wow somebody
said has anything ever been more German
and can i I'll play a hold on holla
I'll play it online has anything ever
been more German Sam Roger a laptop guy
hold on Twitter its Twitter I'm on
Twitter search Twitter underscore laptop
underscore guy I mean you know change it
laptop guy like not even a cool guy to
be alright here we go
this guy whoa whoa whoa yeah
[Music]
oh this is a tick-tock
this guy's [ __ ] wife left him anyway
in the forest and did this he's insecure
Oh insecure ha ha ha
everything is fine the most German [ __ ]
ever dude what is this look it's like a
fish what is it this is weird
what is he saying even do you know I'm
gonna tweet back to this guy oh here I'm
gonna actually tweet it with comment
what is this guy saying any Germans out
there ok no no wow laptop guy came
through with the most German thing of
all time my wife just left me that's
what he's saying
alright cool let's do some miss
connection connection connections let's
do some miss connections here we go
Los Angeles miss connections any female
home alone
it's creepy first of all any female
bored hit me up I can stop by her place
Wow how gentlemanly of you we can smoke
maybe have some drinks it's on me just
looking for good company I'm not that
picky it's okay if you're a little
overweight me I'm average not
bad-looking do not contact me with
unsolicited services offers man that's
[ __ ] sad dude if you're gonna go for
it at least go for it I'm average if
some guy says he's average not
bad-looking he bad-looking you know it's
like if a guy's like you know like was
Brad Pitt saying about himself he's so
handsome he'd be like I mean you know
you know me I do alright I'm okay and
you're like bro you look like a [ __ ]
statue any female bored any female bored
so not picky no girl would ever want
that they want to feel special
okay next new beer tasting buddy Gardena
it was nice meeting you sir last night I
enjoy beer tasting too and I'm glad we
share the same interests I enjoyed your
company since you're a hot old man
probably in his 60s this heavyset chubby
boy is in his late 30s as interested did
not contact me on solicitor's office
this heavyset chubby boy in his late 30s
is interested no doubts thinking about
actually how can you let yourself get
fat ah fat is one thing but like you
know what obese is a problem I get it
you know America doesn't make it easy to
not be fat but if you're a guy that has
all of the stuff you know you have money
you have how are you chubby dude hey guy
guy who's well-off or you know middle
class how are you chubby how are there
any chubby middle-class guys I get if
you're Chuck even if you're rich and
chubby I get it cuz it doesn't matter
you know most guys goals are to get
chicks or or have a family and that
doesn't matter if you're chubby and rich
as [ __ ] you have a family whatever you
do Family Guy if you're a if you're a
chub Meister and you got a [ __ ] money
who cares but if you're middle-class if
you're not poor how the [ __ ] are you
chubby that's your job bro get fit don't
be chubby don't be fat haven't have a
fine body you know you don't have to be
a [ __ ] ripped but there's chubby guys
out there that are middle class I don't
get it and single
huh-huh-huh it's like the guy from
how is that that's the thing that right
there uh-huh
that's and when a chubby guy is
middle-class huh huh how does it happen
dude go to the gym work out lifts some
potted plants run up and down the stairs
in your house I don't get it and I'll
never get it and I won't ever get it and
don't ever expect me to get it anyway
that's it I don't want to do any more
Wow
text me eight one eight two three nine
seventy eighty seven I'm trying to text
back it's a really hard but I have
sending out some videos to people and
stuff like that you can short support
the show by buying merch we got the Life
rips reload coming soon subscribe to the
YouTube channel please really helps us
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market have you
guys seen comedians of the world I was
thinking about that the other day I
don't know how many people saw that I'm
the second episode of comedians of the
world on Netflix go watch that before
you see my new special coming out in a
few months in a few months I would think
I did that and it's very fun you
December 26 very cool I'm gonna be on
the second season of that so have a good
one and oh yeah I'm gonna be on Whitney
Cummings podcast good for you on
Wednesday that's dropping so you can
check me out on that alright guys you
guys are the best thanks for listening
you know I mean
[Music]